C is a general purpose programming
language combining the features of both
high level and low-level languages
resulting in the faster execution and
smoother application development hence
she became one of the first midi level
programming language even today she
helps beginner learn and understand
Computer Logic and programming
fundamentals the widespread use of C
started to take over the IT industry and
owns the caliber to develop and deploy
powerful end-to-end application Level
programs with Unix being the first
operating system design developed and
deployed using C whether you are a
college student or starting your
programming Journey sees the programming
language to go for you are already
watching simply learn and today we have
curated a cheat sheet that will help you
brush your knowledge on important
concepts of C whether it's before your
exam or your interview this C3 sheet
will provide you with all the necessary
knowledge on basic to intermediate
Concepts like data types variables and
constants following that operators like
arithmetic operators relational
operators logical bitwise operators Etc
and advancing we have decision making
statements which allow us to decide the
order of execution of statements like if
statement if statements and else if
lather statements then we have a
conditional control statement which
would enable multi-wave branching after
that we have loops that allow us to
iterate through a part of the program
several times following that we have
covered various Concepts like array
strings pointers and finally structures
and file handling if you like this video
share it with your friends for last
minute revisions And subscribe to the
simply learn channel for more
interesting videos and press the Bell
icon to never miss an update from Simply
learn the link to the full cheat sheet
is in the description box below I hope
it really helped you all thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning